[Music]
some say I'm the best in the world I
agree with them I'm Lena Messi I let my
football speak for itself
say your name
Kevin people said I couldn't carry Egypt
they were arrived people say I lack
focus I say focus on this rules are
meant to be broken
so is masala I'm not here to make
friends I'm here to make history I'm not
here to make friends either but if I did
make a friend that'd be nice because I'm
a bit lonely at real at first I thought
it was a language barrier thing but now
I speak some Spanish and still man you
more like man me I don't dress to
impress I dress to gag and press he tell
us some more about yourself Kevin the
branagh remember that amazing goal I
scored it to win the puskás neither do i
i am paul and i know how to make
headlines sure limit the omaha chester
care to Noel Gallagher I'm so good I'm
in the MLS and they still put me in this
intro everybody knows I'm at the same
level as Messi and Ronaldo why is
everybody laughing football is in my
veins forget John Terry I'm the real mr.
steal your girl what of your windows
board up your windows it's harry kane
season bayern is not sleeping we're just
giving other teams and Bundesliga a head
start
I dress in all black because every game
is a funeral for the other team right
now the show is good people are happy
but wait until season 3 things will go
very bad
I'm Fellini and in this show I will
never cut my hair
sorry sorry I'm late hello i'm i am very
happy for luca that he won the Ballon
d'Or what Phil Jones and nobody wants to
face me oh sure yeah
wait I've taught this I kick shins and
knees like their boss
I also kick balls like their boss I am
so pumped to join Chelsea because I was
in danger of actually winning things at
Dortmund and that would go against
everything the US Men's National Team
believes him every time he gets a bad
result I take a hard look in the mirror
and that blames officials so we end the
cut of the grass the smells of the
stadium and back and winning is in my
genes if you need a cross into the box
pray you have an unhealthy win money
can't buy you silverware is what the
Chairman keeps telling me don't hate me
because I'm beautiful hate me because I
had a great World Cup five years ago and
not much else I'm not the new Bernardo
I'm the first Vinicius oh except for
Vinicius senior despite recent results
we already got the historic quadruple
this season we were investigated by UEFA
FIFA the FA and the Premier League I
followed in the footsteps of the greats
by leaving Southampton you think a card
is a dog I shagged me brothers missing
all right and that's all we need thank
you for coming in mr. Giggs I'm one of
the best players in the world according
to my paycheck people say I would be
good in the Premier League but first I
need to be good in Syria thanks Kappa
but we actually need a Champions League
goalkeeper so you just go ahead and get
off the set look at the crap
I'm staying you can't make me go please
who's back it's go be all right
[Music]
and for my next trick I will make myself
reappear as a relevant player now that
the transfer window is over I can spend
more time pursuing my hobbies
you know like playing football hi this
is me Christian Eriksen I love to play
football for Tottenham Hotspur I'm so
happy
watch out Champions League it's time for
a land at a rocky world
it's Atalanta I am so sick about the
vanity and the egos in Paris that is why
next season I'm going to Miami if you
come and Napoli be proud to get a pizza
me ever since I was a young boy I
dreamed of playing for you the among the
culture and just women there don't
overlook Olympiacos this Halloween I
dressed up is a real Premier League man
hat trick or treat
ever since coming to Barcelona it's been
difficult to connect with Messi he's
never on line can just hold on for one
second I want to send this it's going to
be so funny oh no oh no the littleit
elite elite
[Music]